welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and the She-Hulk season finale ended in
the most mind-bendingly amazing Way by
Smashing that fourth wall to have a
conversation with a robot Kevin feige
with a tiny black hat on a Marvel
Studios lot the way that every Marvel
Studio show should end but while it was
crazy dope to see the MCU Crossover with
elements of our reality I could not help
but have a feeling that Marvel Studios
could be teasing the coming of a fan
favorite Marvel hero gwenpool to the MCU
and today we are going to talk about why
my nerd babies but first do not forget
to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com today
tonight to pick up our newest latest
Obsession shirts inspired by both G Hulk
and House of the Dragon The Shield
shirts are about to go away very soon
because she Hulk the show has ended so
pick up one of those shirts or any one
of our amazing pieces of nerd options
over at rockstarsmash.com today alright
so right when I realized that Jennifer
Walters had taken matters into her own
Jolly Green Giant hands in brings
skedude onto the Marvel Studios launch
to change the course of her story my
heart left with joy like there was some
type of frog themed superhero with jet
fuel powered rocket boots
that's right everybody my heart can wear
boots not just because we got to see a
live-action She-Hulk have a chat with
her creators about the direction of her
story like the character does in the
comics a lot but mostly because in
Marvel Studios just canonized a variant
of our own IRL Universe within the MCU
Multiverse continuity with the main
difference being that our Kevin feige
has a human body with two eyes two legs
and uh too many hats but you know what
they work for him want to give me one of
those hats Kevin I will gladly accept
this is huge to me because this could
have very well been our first look into
the universe of one Gwendolyn pool in
the MCU continuity now if you aren't
already familiar with the character from
the comics when pool's real name is
literally Wendell in pool and she
originally came from a universe nearly
identical to ours where Marvel Comics
were super popular and being adapted to
like various different types of media
and Gwendolyn was a huge comic book fan
herself showing up to her local comic
book shop nearly every Wednesday for the
newest Marvel comic releases because
Gwendolyn like a lot of comic book nerds
out there like myself use Comics as a
form of escapism to distract herself
from the crappiness of her own life like
you know being unable to find a job
after a failing high school or losing
all of her friends until one day out of
nowhere unexplained to this day
Gwendolyn gets transported from The Real
World into the Marvel Comics universe
and the ability to manipulate hop
through and Destroy comic book panels
and Pages at will because she is not
native to that universe and she knows
that she's in a comic book like this
girl has become a God and after Gwen
comes to the conclusion that the only
way to survive in a superhero comic book
world is to become a superhero and stand
out herself a random superhero tailor
that she finds mistakens her name Gwen
Poole as gwenpool and Designs a pink
suit modeled after her pink hair but
also very much inspired by Deadpool
despite Gwendolyn herself ironically not
really being a fan of Deadpool comics
which is kind of hilarious considering
the Deadpool s Carefree attitude that
she had about murdering fictional comic
book people at least you know at first
anyway but when she learned that her
comic book reality was just as real as
her own reality in its own weird way
gwenpool becomes a lot more restrained
as to how she goes about trying to stand
out in Marvel Comics so they don't you
know kill her off or cancel her and opts
to become a mercenary instead despite
you know having no combat skills
whatsoever like she's literally just a
comic book nerd but hey with a couple of
katanas guns and explosives and the
ability to manipulate the rules of the
comic book medium that you're in who
really needs combat training anyway it's
really just a suggestion and look gang
she helped maybe coming to a close but
if you love the show you can still have
She-Hulk clothes see what I did there
close that's right it's March time since
She-Hulk is ending latest Obsession
number 19 is going back to the dungeon
never to be seen again so this is the
last chance to get this epic hero
exclusive so do not miss out and while
you're poking around epicurershop.com
find out check out the rest of the
collection there's the Superhuman La
division crew neck and the girl boss
t-shirt that would look amazing on your
person and devil's advocate he might be
The Man Without Fear but bat Murdoch is
not lacking in game if you know what I'm
saying
happy ever slept with a green woman I
think not
hahaha
look at how cute these tees look
together match made in heaven and I mean
it's enough to make somebody want to
wear multiple tees at once which is not
normally how I do it because sweating is
the thing but hey why not wear two
T-shirts at the same time you just need
extra layers and snagging submerged from
Epicure shop is the absolute best number
one way to support the channel and
wearing that merch is the best way to
spot fans in the wild so make sure to
wear it to screenings parties or while
handing out candy to Neighborhood kids
also be sure to tag at epic hero shop
and use the hashtag real epic hero to
get featured on their page get
everything you need to be the stylisher
that you know that you are at
epicureshop.com today this all being
said by having a copy of our Earth
appear in the She-Hulk finale Marvel
Studios has basically confirmed in my
eyes that gwenpool exists within the MCU
continuity and considering that we do
have Deadpool 3 going into production so
soon this could be the mcu's way of
furthering their Multiverse narrative by
including our universe within that
Multiverse story through the
introduction of more characters like
your she-hulks like your Deadpools and
like your gwenpools that can interact
with the audience directly I think in
their own clever way we just saw what
could be a potential Catalyst for
gwenpool's arrival to the MCU proper
likely through a She-Hulk season 2
because of anybody is going to need a
lawyer after they just stabbed several
men in the throat with the defense that
they were MCU background characters uh
it's it's going cool and by having she
helped introduce us to a world mirrored
after our own during this Multiverse
Saga gwenpool now has a direct means of
getting into
she has only experience through the
movies so far like she literally can
just follow She-Hulk from The Real World
into the Disney plus menu into the MCU
and gwenpool would now also potentially
have a perfect Mentor in Jennifer
Walters as Jennifer Walters is one of
the only few characters inside of the
entire MCU outside of you know Deadpool
that knows that her universe is only
here for the entertainment of others us
we never want our heroes to know peace
because that would be boring Peter
Parker will never be happy
laughs
suffer Peter so yeah I would definitely
expect this crazy ass killer in pink to
show up in the MCU very soon like Troy
Bolton in High School Musical 2 I would
bet on it
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertonment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
really fun theories but more importantly
you could follow new rock stars wherever
we are on the social medias and again do
not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com today so you can buy
our newest latest Obsession shirts
inspired by both She-Hulk and House of
the Dragon they are about to go away
very soon so pick those up today but
again thank you guys so much for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys very soon
alright goodbye foreign
[Music]
pool is very popular